what's up guys
bang bang it is lunch money time on a
friday you know i got that friday
friday energy everyone knows friday
energy's the best on fridays we don't
put milk and then pour a little bit of
coffee on fridays we don't pour the milk
and then put a little bit of cereal
on friday we do normal things like do
lunch money everybody knows that
don't forget that lunch money is now
sponsored by block five block five has
three products you can buy
and sell your cryptocurrencies you can
take your crypto you could deposit into
uh interest paying account earn up to
8.6
apy or you can deposit crypto and take
out a usd loan against your crypto
collateral
please please please i'm an investor i
sit on the board please make me happy
and please go sign up for a blackfy
account
you can go to blockfly.com pomp
blackfy.com pomp we can make a whole
little song if anyone makes a beat i'll
tweet it
blockfy.com slash pomp
all right that's going to be in your
nightmares tonight what's up
okay it's late it's 2 38 i haven't eaten
a single thing today i've been grinding
all day for you people but that's okay
i'm here i went on jim o'shaughnessy's
podcast that you should listen to when
it comes out
that's not part of the news oh sorry
okay joe biden
on thursday unveiled the details of a
1.9 trillion coronavirus rescue package
designed to support households and
businesses through the pandemic
it calls for direct payments of fourteen
hundred dollars to most americans
increases the federal per week
unemployment benefit to 400 increases
the federal minimum wage to fifteen
dollars an hour
and more things what did you tweet the
other day that was like we're trying to
trying to cure a virus what was it
they're trying to cure the virus with
monetary stimulus but that ain't how it
works
you want to know what they should do
what i've been saying it for a year
it'd be wild wild idea open the economy
why you don't pass any legislation all
you got to say okay but how would you
respond to the people who are getting
sick when you open the economy
stay inside if you are
old or you're have pre uh conditions
pre-existing pre-existing conditions
that's fine by the way it doesn't matter
what i think they're going to print the
money they're going to come in with 1.9
trillion more dollars they're going to
just
go ahead and drop the bomb on us that's
on top of the 900 billion that they did
at the end of the year that's on top of
the two trillion dollars that they did
last year
so we're already over four trillion here
comes another 1.9
that is going to get us to six trillion
dollars go back check the tweets i said
that they were gonna have to do over
five trillion people laughed at me here
comes
six over the top and as we all know all
they're gonna do is pump
asset prices they are going to literally
send stocks
real estate gold bitcoin
um can i ask a question yes how do you
feel about the fact that i look like an
angel today okay what's the next topic
okay so gemini trust the cryptocurrency
exchange and custodian
what i didn't see what you did founded
by twins tyler and cameron
winklevoss could soon go public
uh the winklevoss twins said in an
interview they're considering taking the
new york-based digital asset from public
due to the rising interest in
cryptocurrencies is this a good idea
yeah of course it's great business why
would they not take it publicly why are
you smiling
i was just reminiscing about yesterday
when i was yawning and i kept fighting
off my yawns
but i would didn't really be very
successful but that's okay
you didn't really be very successful no
i can't speak today either but that's
okay i learned a lot about yawning i
appreciate all of you giving me a bunch
of misinformation in the comments
because there was nobody that was right
uh and then second of all was uh i did
see that a lot of you thought it was
very funny when i
went like this to plano which i thought
was pretty funny uh i think that gemini
should go public
why why not go take a great business put
in the public markets let investors
get exposure to it i'm sure there's a
bunch of people who are into crypto that
would love to get exposure to it
cool by the way can i just say one other
thing about cameron tyler
yeah i will keep banging this drum until
people start listening
they're going to go down as some of the
best investors in the world
in the world cameron and tyler
winklevoss are going to end up being
seen as some of the best investors in
the world can i just say something
that would be a nice sequel to the
social network
i would love to watch that movie i think
there's a sequel to the book
is that correct kind of oh okay it's
called
billionaires
that is so violent
go ahead
nobody wants to see that again
i can do it too all right so but you
look like one of them birds trying to
swoop down and get a worm off the ground
that got lost and ended up just ramming
their beak
into the ground so there is a
new profile on spotify that you should
read it's in bloomberg
business week beyond that you do kind of
look like a
how do bird look like a squirrel okay
spotify's i didn't say a word
but now beyond the profile spotify's big
bet on podcasts is
failing says city uh
spotify's multi-million dollar bet on
podcasting may not be working out city
analysts wrote in a note to clients on
friday
the idea was that by bringing exclusive
content to the app the company could
strengthen its advertising business
but now analysts are looking for the
company to show that investments were
worth it
these people must not be parents that's
what i've determined parents yeah these
analysts they can't be parents wait why
because they've never seen something
start out small and grow over time into
something big
they just never seen that because they
they're like oh you want to do podcasts
great you made an acquisition
six months later why are we not famous
rich and uh just printing money
because it takes time relax get six
months into this and they're freaking
out
literally q3 2020 and they're acting
like all of a sudden you're supposed to
be the next amazon like chill out
let them execute their strategy they're
six months most of you analysts couldn't
even find your car after work let alone
figure out what to do in six months
chill it probably took you six weeks to
write the report chill out
it'll be okay let them do their work
they're gonna be fine they're gonna keep
execute
and i'm willing to bet the podcast isn't
gonna work out because when an analyst
writes and says it ain't gonna work out
usually that means something else a
mickey mantle baseball card has
shattered a five-month-old record for
highest selling sports card of all time
going for five 5.2
million dollars do i sound like a game
analyst
announcer okay do i
it got me i don't know if you guys just
saw that yawn got me
i tried real hard i was gonna pretend
like it didn't happen but it happened so
i feel like i'm just gonna come i'm just
gonna come on this with you
i promise i come in peace
i like how yesterday you were like stop
stop it
yeah something like i will talk to
myself you know like i said
i send a good email y'all never see me
said that was good email
that's right that was a great email
right there like start treating email
like sports no problem
uh by the way uh speaking of sports the
sports card 5.2 million we're going to
see a card get sold for 10 million
i don't know which one it's gonna be i
don't know who's gonna buy it i don't
know who's gonna get rich selling it
but it's gonna happen it's just they're
all
i need a profile card okay
oh that was a good click of the car of
the computer that was a great click
right there great form i liked the
pressure
right there that was perfect are you
doing everything like sports now
i could okay oh that was a long pause
she's going to pay for that one later
scientists want to do something
very controversial which is they want to
shorten the minute 60 seconds to 59
seconds at least for one negative leap
second
that will better line us up with the
earth's
real rotation right now we're not
aligned guys
we need to be aligned that means that
we need a negative leap second what do
you think i feel like you'd have a lot
of opinions on this
what y'all know what the earth time is
how you know what the earth's clock says
did you see it
because did you see it this is a
listen did an alarm clock go off and it
was a second off this is on the heels of
a year marked by many
shorter than average days following
several years in which earth has rotated
faster
than maybe ever ever before what's good
also wait i saw a really funny
tweet that said this news organization
tweeted the earth
is rotating faster and faster
and then this girl was like i hear you
girl
can i be honest i'm spinning faster and
faster
too yeah can i be honest what time's
made up we made it up time isn't real
it's true we just made it up this is all
it's all nonsense
i mean who who was like we should call
it three o'clock
why's it gonna be called three o'clock
why can't it be called something else
what why does that have to be called
three weird
okay time isn't real ready no no this is
important
so why what do they mean it's a second
off
think about that for a second this
sounds like some funny business
shout out christine lagarde ecb
president from yesterday
it sounds like some funny business that
they're just trying to prepare us
because the aliens are here i think
that's what it is i think they're trying
to get us to
change our clocks a little bit to throw
off the aliens but they don't want to
tell us the aliens are here
it's ask lunch money time which means
you can ask your question with hashtag
asklm in the comments
this question comes from zandy js
i thought that went off like a beast i
know you all saw that go ahead don't
steal the thunder
go ahead sorry sandy j
j s hey guys what do you think is the
best way to gain cash flow
instead of working at nine to five job
also when will the joke of the day
return
the joke is gone i might return it well
you're here so the joke is
always here oh i'm gonna be in trouble
for that
you don't even know you don't even know
that means she has a joke that she's
going to try to pull out later uh i
think that the best thing you could do
for cash flow
is one of two things either one you
could try to build a business that
solves a problem for somebody so figure
out
why she has a nine-to-five job instead
of working
at nine to five dang somebody can't read
i was just saying i thought you wanted
to do it it was in english sorry
do you i speak better english than your
program that's a fact that is a fact
uh i speak gibberish uh but um
yeah so one is you could solve a problem
for somebody and basically say hey look
you've got a problem i can solve it you
should pay me to solve your problem
that's how you get cash flow
or two is i actually think uh gary
vaynerchuk's been
all over this uh for a while now uh
which is like flipping things so
you can go and i fought it off
wow the yawn god
is active in our house come on come on
um
is you can basically sell things but the
way that you can sell things is to go
buy them for cheaper and then turn
around and sell them somewhere else
so his whole thing is like you can go to
a
yard sale you could buy something that
you know is worth 20 bucks you buy for
one dollar there and then churn you go
sell for 20 bucks gets a little bit of
cash flow
i think it's a little bit harder for
people just because it takes a lot of
time effort all that kind of stuff
so one of the things that i do recommend
immensely immensely is that there's all
kinds of things you can do on the
internet
um and so it's like rather than just
trying to solve a problem for people who
are
local to you if you have a skill let's
say that you're a
digital school you've got your designer
or you can write well or you can do
whatever
or you just want to do manual labor like
you're literally like i'll just sit here
in the spreadsheet and just click around
for
three hours and i'll get paid money you
can find all kinds of jobs on the
internet so i would suggest you go do
that
yeah i like this uh naval quote or
question
or yeah i think it was a question he
said basically
what can you do that feels like play to
you
but work to everybody else for me that's
writing i think most people are like oh
but i enjoy it so if you can find that i
think that's great
okay chris weems would you guys
consider yourselves minimalists
questions stemming from pumps clean and
simple outfits
i've been curious about this while you
were reading the question i got attacked
again
i saw you and i ignored you it got me
can you put your head so you block
thank you no yeah there we go so uh i
got
big ass so chris what do you have to say
for chris are you a minimalist
i don't know if i would call it i feel
like minimalism is uh
attached to creative uh type mentality
and also like good design like when
you're like oh that house is minimal no
i think he means it's like it's like
real smooth and nice and
it looks good everything and then you
just see me and you're like man that
dude's got a t-shirt on that he's owned
for six years i think if i have a hole
in it nike
you this is a nike that's a nike check
but the nike check is gone like whatever
i think i'm more of just uh i'm pretty
cheap actually
like uh you know i only own two pairs of
jeans i'll used to only own one but
pluto made me buy a second one and i
have two because
one of them is ripped that's another
situation um i have two pairs of shoes
one for running
and one for everything else uh including
dress
everything just is where the other ones
for everything um and then you know
i basically just want to streamline my
decision making
uh it's probably the biggest thing so i
wear black t-shirt and jeans every day
i have like three pairs of athletic
shorts
and three shirts and i just put them on
if i need athletic gear
or i put on other things if i need other
things just jeans shirt
done so i got i don't know if it's so
much minimalism as just like
not being stupid like i don't want to
have complex decisions to make
unlike our friend here who's like i make
sure should i wear the blue shirt or the
red shirt or the green shirt
i'll tell you the white shirt but yeah
and i'm like
i don't know you look great in all of
them thank you
that's it for today guys thank you chris
for the question
if you guys will if you you would really
make me happy if you could please go to
readtheprofile.com and sign up for
plano's newsletter
she will be very happy which means that
i will have a good life and i will
be able to go to dinner tonight and live
my weekend
in peace so please go to
readtheprofile.comreadtheprofile.com
sign up let her know that you signed up
in the comments and tell her
that her amazing smart intelligent
uh intellectually high horsepower
husband that was three terms for smart
uh sent you to sign up for the profile
thank you guys appreciate you
bang bang hope you guys enjoyed this
episode of lunch money as much as we did
and don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block five so go check them
out there's a link in the description
that you can click
on i'm an investor a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block five
than you are of me
block five is my second favorite thing
in the world behind paulina they've got
three products
they can give you a us dollar loan you
can earn up to 8.6
interest on an interest-bearing account
or you can buy and sell cryptocurrencies
on their crypto exchange
i personally use the interest bearing
account there's not very many places
where you'll find
up to 8.6 interest on a deposit in an
interest bearing account
go do your own research there's risk
associated but 8.6
is pretty compelling so click on the
link in the description say thanks to
the folks at blockfly
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling in the comments
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends